So, if you believe the postulates, let's do some amazing things.
So, I'm sorry to say but the train is back.
Train show up all the time in special relativity. Don't ask me why.
But joining this train are clocks held by two observers, green and red.
I don't know why but their parents named them after the color of their hair.
Now, what's going to happen here is that green, well, standing on this train
and the train is moving with some velocity v relative to the ground.
Well, she's going to do a little experiment.
She is going to take her flashlight and bring it down to ground level.
She's going to send a beam of light straight up
so that it bounces off a mirror and then come straight back down
and she's going to time how long it takes the beam of light to make this round trip.
I should mention the train has a height we call h.
Well, now that we're studying relativity,
we've really to think about whose point of view we're solving the problem from
and first I think about the train point of view.
From the point of view of the train, this is the right drawing to draw.
From green's point of view it looks like, well, she doesn't know the train is at rest,
so it looks like the light goes straight up then comes straight back down.
So we drew a little arrow here showing that this represents the green point of view.
From the red point of view, well as the train speeds by,
it's not going to look like the beam of light goes straight upwards.
It's going to go over at some angle then bounce back down
and be collected and observed.
One thing that's potentially confusing here that I should point out
I've tried drawing both of these perspectives on one train that's difficult to do.
The red observer will not see the light leave from this portion of the train
and then end up on this portion of the train in front of this front wheel
because the train would have move forward as well.
Okay. Great.
So, we've got our two frames of reference, the green frame and the red frame,
and the light seems to take different trajectories in each frame.
Let's call this total distance traveled up and down in the green frame equal to d
and the total distance the light spends traveling in the red frame d’.
This prime is what we're going to use often in special relativity to indicate a different frames.
We have our two different frames.
Everything that we're talking about in the red head frame, we'll put a prime on.
Now, my question is which of these paths are longer?
Actually, what I really want to know is which of these statements are true.
Is the distance traveled in the green frame less than,
equal to, or greater than the distance traveled in the prime frame?